hey I'm Cameron Boyce from descendants
and you're watching Disney Channel
[Music]
now that's artwork Disney Channel star
Cameron Boyce has died he was 20 years
old a rap on behalf of Cameron's family
confirm the news to ET on Sunday
explaining that the actor died of a
seizure in his sleep Saturday night
which was a result of an ongoing medical
condition which he was being treated for
quote the world is now undoubtedly
without one of its brightest lights but
his spirit will live on through the
kindness and compassion of all who knew
and loved him Cameron was known for
starring in several Disney Channel
projects including Jessie I think we
just got discovered I knew I was good I
didn't know I was sausage good and his
role in The Descendants franchise as
Carlos the son of Cruella De Vil whoa
don't you ever miss screaming at people
and just making them run away from you
you're thinking of my mother and I was
usually on the other end of that so not
really know et spoke with Cameron in
2017 just weeks before the second
Descendants film debuted its how to be
up the ante fer the second it's gonna be
difficult honestly right because I mean
the first one was really big and when we
first heard about you know we're doing a
sequel we were like all right how are we
gonna top the first one but I think we
did I think that everything is bigger
the sets the the choreography the
numbers all of it is a really high
energy and high stakes and stuff like
that so it's pretty it's pretty fun
Cameron also starred in grownups and
grownups too
wait get right it Adam Sandler who
played Cameron's on-screen dad tweeted
his condolences writing in part quote
too young too sweet too funny
just the nicest most talented and most
decent kid around stars like Yara
Shahidi Charlie puth James Charles and
zendaya also shared heartfelt messages
aside from acting Cameron always
prioritized giving back in May Cameron
opened up to outliving magazine about
his charity work telling the mad quote
it's the greatest way to fulfill
yourself in April 2018 he was honored
for his work with the thirst project
which aims to bring safe drinking water
to communities around the world what you
leave should be bigger than you we need
to use what we have and make the world a
better place for other people other
people people who need us